patriot hall of famer and one of our
favorites from back in the day at the
nfl network when he was playing in the
nfl protecting the blind side of
tom brady joining us here on the rich
eisen show is our friend matt light how
are you matt
my man mr rich it has been a long time
it has been it's been way too long so
two things i wanted to have you on to
talk about this and your and your
foundation and two to personally thank
you for uh beating michigan state a
couple of weeks ago so
that was very helpful to the to my alma
mater so good stuff out of uh out of you
boilermaker good stuff out of you yeah
buddy i got a daughter that's there as a
sophomore and uh while last year was
tough for anybody that has kids or
you know school-aged you know uh
siblings or whatever
this year has made up for it and in
large part just the excitement of that
team i mean those guys are playing
really well didn't didn't go so well for
him and uh
columbus last week that'll happen but uh
that'll happen yeah they've got they've
got two really good players but listen
when i heard you talk earlier about this
atlanta super bowl yes sir it brought me
back to i left uh the super bowl that
year with my lovely wife susie and we
were flying back during the entire
game right so i'm on a plane
with my headphones watching a little
seat back screen and
miserable i mean it was and by the way
we're going into boston and
half the plane
were clearly falcons fans or they just
despise new england for some unknown
reason and
for that turn of events to happen in
such a small space where seemingly
everything was going right for everyone
on the plane but my wife and i and then
to have them win that was that was a
kind of unique way to watch that one
yeah man i mean on twitter too uh it was
let's go to jimmy g brady's done like
brady's career is over at halftime of
that game you know that's what was being
said and then they moved on to the
second half which was cincinnati you
know uh on steroids you know and uh and
the rest is history so uh i i'll place
to you in front of you matt light um who
was there and watched it all go down uh
earlier this week um i said that mac
jones
is operating this offense
just like brady did when he had his
first crack at it in that first year in
2001 and then kurt warner even went on
uh and and and raised it and said that
mac jones is being asked to do more and
is actually doing more than what brady
did you were there what do you think
when you see mac jones run this offense
right now
well it looks really good and that's
coming from the standpoint if you if you
go back and look at you know weeks one
through five you saw him making good
decisions you saw him making some good
throws but what we really came away with
watching mack in in in those early few
weeks was the fact that this kid was
getting destroyed i mean he would
release the ball and get leveled and
these weren't little hits these were
legal hardcore hits that would have
shaken up any quarterback in the
national football league and the thing
that really
got my attention was the fact that not
only did he continue to stand in there
and make great throws but he didn't get
discouraged and he didn't try to do more
than he should and a lot of those things
are reminiscent of how tommy played
right i mean go out there don't make
mistakes manage the offense we got a
good running game we're gonna you know
ground and pound when we can and that
running game as it always does opens up
the passing game and there are a lot of
similarities between those two but i
wouldn't say that
you know mac jones is being asked to do
more than tom did because in that in
that first year there were so many
things that people didn't realize going
on with injuries and this that and the
other tommy managed it about as good as
you could do for a guy stepping in so
give me give me some of those things we
might not be aware of from brady's first
season
that you're talking about
well i mean look
the number of times i can tell you this
much the number of times that number 12
in new england and i'm sure you know
there's times where it's happened down
there in tampa
went out in that field where he was
75 80 percent dealing with you know a
toe or dealing with an ankle or dealing
with a hand dealing with a shoulder
dealing with broken ribs i mean he's one
of the toughest players and you don't
hear that very much from offensive
linemen talking about quarterbacks so i
know that so are
the fact that you're being coy right now
are you telling me that as a retired man
a grown ass man that 20 years later
you're still afraid of talking about
injuries about the patriots from 20
years ago am i picking that up
am i picking that up like
because that's the rule like you you're
still even in retirement not allowed to
talk about 20 year old injuries from a
season oh just just hold on a second the
belichick drone's about ready to fly
over i'll have about a three second
window here
well done matt well done so no but but
looking at jones do you see moments
where it looks like that that looks
exactly what tom did in that first year
do you have moments like that well
yeah for sure i mean and listen and
talking to the guys that are playing
there now you know the david andrews and
you know guys that have been there and
and their leaders in their own right
one of the things they said back during
training camp before anybody saw what
this kid was going to do when the
bullets were flying for real they kept
saying hey man i've got faith in this
kid this this kid came in he's ready to
work he's ready to get it done so that
told me everything i needed to know
going into i didn't have question marks
whether or not they brought in the right
guy it was just okay what's going to
happen when it really you know comes
down to it and there's one of those
situations but look this kid continues
to impress he continues to get better
and i would say that as a whole
my biggest worry for this team this year
was not mac jones it was hey you brought
in a lot of different chess pieces how
in the world are you going to get them
all to play together
in in season one and it's taken a little
bit of time to develop those things but
as you noted earlier the defense is
playing really good football really good
fundamental football and the secondary
up front the whole nine the offense is
getting it done again the running game
in my opinion is key and that's opening
up everything else but they got a
quarterback that can make the throws
yeah matt light here on the rich either
show three-time super bowl champion look
man
it's always dicey to even twitch in the
direction that i i twitched in earlier
this week and i'm doing with you right
now because it it the the ultimate
headline is
you know mac jones is
another tom brady you know and clearly
there's only one of those we'll never
see another like tom ever
and
that said though
having somebody run the offense
in the manner that looks efficient
and smart
and that could blossom into somebody who
can make any comeback happen at any
fourth quarter
during a season
like do you think we're gonna start
seeing that sort of stuff out of mac
jones like is that the next level that
we're gonna start seeing because we're
already seeing
the bradyesque type performance in the
first year at quarterback
matt well look i mean look at the
similarities right they got
tommy comes in the league has bill
belichick matt comes in the league he's
got bill belichick that's a big part of
the equation right i'm not saying that
bill did everything i'm not saying that
tommy was responsible for everything i'm
just saying when you put a combination
of you know arguably the best coach in
nfl history with a kid that wants to get
better every day is competitive as hell
and works his tail off to make sure that
he does it better tomorrow than he did
today you should expect to see
a guy that's going to make plays like
tom did now
there's a lot of other factors that go
into that too and and we all know that
the length of the season when you get
from college to the nfl takes a toll on
you injuries take a toll on you but i
wouldn't say it's a stretch to assume
that we'll see a progression much like
we did with 12 because this kid has that
it factor look at all the other teams
that don't have it it's really easy to
see when you don't have it um we have it
here in new england yeah and and i had
matthew judon a couple weeks ago and i
asked him about mac jones and one of the
things that he said he liked about him
and that he noticed is the spirit that
he takes coaching with
and that sounds like he's being ridden
pretty damn hard uh did brady get
written listen hey hey
right now man it no one was off limits
that's one of the things that look it's
not easy playing in new england it's not
easy you know under a belichick coach
system and that's a fact a lot of guys
came from other places couldn't believe
that you know we had full pads on now
this is back in the day when we actually
wore full pads but you know couldn't
believe that
bill wrote us as hard as he did but no
one's ever off limits tom brady got dog
cussed and and was on the low light reel
as much as any other player his first
year or throughout
oh man all the way to the end my friend
no kidding
so here he is he's a three-time champion
whatever and he's getting he's getting
circled and dog cost is what you're
saying
yeah listen and and there's a part of
you as a competitor as it you know we
all know that there's hierarchy in this
world right i mean not everybody gets
into the fancy country club they
definitely don't look at me and say hey
let's open the doors for that one but
when you're everybody's expected to do
the same thing every bill demands
everything from everyone so it's kind of
nice to know that nobody is in a
pedestal we were all in the same hole
the same pit of despair right
from one of my favorite movies but nice
we were all in it together right and i
think that there's a little bit of
comfort in that um
knowing that you know hey look it
doesn't matter how many dollars you know
you're pulling in or you know what your
name is on the back your jersey we're
all treated the same matt light here on
the rich eisen show before i let you go
let's hit on your foundation we do that
every single time i love that your matte
light foundation is still lit um and
once again you're giving away a
one-of-a-kind experience to a patriot
game and it's not just any patriot game
it's the one coming up against the
titans next week with mike vrabel
coming into the house again
um that's gonna be amazing how can
people get involved and get uh what do
they get for this package matt well
listen we've got a suite given to us a
good friend of ours uh for little town
amended imperial motors gave us his
entire suite said raise as much for the
light foundation as you possibly can so
if you go to
matlite72.com and you want to go to the
titans game you got all the information
there you'll be at the titans game in
style in a suite all the booze all the
food everything done for you the coveted
parking pass yes and then i've brought
in uh two very dear friends and uh
former teammates mr matt castle and rob
ninkovich we're gonna do a little chalk
talk before the game and then enjoy the
game together and all the proceeds 100
go to the light foundation you could
just go to matlat72.com and mr brable is
going to have a video message for us and
i guarantee you it will be
very blessed now you you've worked with
brayboy you've heard vrable i tell
people all the time don't ever get into
a war of words with mike brabel he'll
make you look silly in a flash he has
got the gift of of gab when it comes to
just tearing people apart i used to love
it when we played together because he
always had something fun to say and he
always gave it to bill too and i'll tell
you rich if you go think back to that
game that they played i think it was the
first time
as vrable as the head coach and bill
coming into tennessee and bill tried to
run a trick play and the next series and
and it failed miserably the next series
brabel had his offense run it and it ran
smoothly and i said that's my voice
that's the mike ravel i know well i mean
belichick a couple of years ago um
had uh
some you know
he he found some um
loophole in the rule book against the
jets where you know you you could run
the clock down by
purposely what false starting or jumping
offsides or something
and they cut to belichick and he's got
this smile on his face and vrabel used
it against belichick in the playoff game
that brady's final game is a patriot
like so he's
he's got he's got that in him man and
he's got coach of the year written all
over him right now all over him listen
he he he's an amazing mind i mean
everybody talked about it when he was in
new england how much of a
a coach he was on the field you know as
a player
and uh vrabel
he exudes everything that is football
man his tenacity kind of the way he
played the game with an edge all day
every day you know doing every little
thing he could do to get better i mean
bill loved him but what bill didn't like
is is that you can't
you can't put mike brabel in a box so
you know i used to love watching those
two go back and forth it may be in a
meeting you know vrable had some quick
little
you know
line to deliver to bill when he was
giving us hell about something and and
you know i don't think that after our
era there were too many guys walking
into new england bus and bill's chops
right it just doesn't happen much
anymore i mean i think he hit that
plateau but uh we sure do look fondly
back on those moments and it's fun to
see that on the field they're still
carrying on some of those shenanigans
matt light72.com
chalk talk to get your opportunity to
have that uh once in a lifetime if
you're in the boston area pretty neat
stuff matt great chat with you let's do
it again soon
yes sir take care brother you got it
that's matt light right here on the rich
eisen show former new england patriot
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here